i get curious as to like i remember i
was working at a restaurant they had a
bus boy there
that was an older guy and he was doing
steroids in it uh
and so we would go to the gym together
and next thing you know it was just like
something we did
right you know and um and he was older
than me this guy so sometimes i went
looking back i wonder would i have done
it if it wasn't like an
older person if it had just been a buddy
i don't think too much on it but
sometimes i just like to look back at
like
you know where was like the influence
coming from or was the influence coming
from inside of me like wanting something
um different or wanting a different
experience you know wanting
to like put anything into myself right
to replace something inside of me that
was missing
right yeah which is the story of our
lives totally
right later in life releasing something
that's already inside of me yeah but i'm
looking for external answers
or external things to fill that void but
really the answer is inside of me
right yeah but it doesn't feel like it
is because it feels like there's nothing
inside
once you get sober clear-headed and kind
of can start reflecting on life as you
get older
yeah you that's when at least for me my
experiences i start to see
i was like the dog chasing my tail yeah
looking for this looking for that and
it's like the whole answer is like with
me the whole time
yeah it's just like stop take a look
slow down you know breathe
and yeah but the catalyst for the actual
steroid taking was i couldn't
bench 315 because that's three big
plates on each side
oh yeah but i could do 295 for like five
reps but i couldn't do 315 for one so
it was like a psychological block and i
got on like some really light steroids
and like within two weeks i was like at
three
benching like 325 damn so i was like oh
they definitely work
well we got on some vietnamese [ __ ] one
time i don't even think it helped me
lift they helped me cook
it definitely helped me like i could run
dude i'm not even joking
i could cook over a fire suddenly in my
yard but i could not
[ __ ] do it because we got some gutter
steroids that came through
man like we got like bottom of the
barrel
was it like top of it taped clothes yeah
it was
like a wrist it wasn't even sealed and
stuff i remember
one time we all went to mexico on a
class trip so we came back
literally people would buy stories and
then put them in shampoo bottles just
kind of rinse them out a little
no and just pour it in there oh my god
so then for like
people are just pulling up at this
dude's house and just syringing out of
this
you know head and shoulders unreal you
know and that's it i mean it got you
it got you both of those bitcoin
pharmaceuticals
[Laughter]
holy smokes but yeah we had some of the
cleanest muscles in town right we'll say
that
well you're willing to go to any lengths
right oh totally that's the question
that
it's like i really was yeah and so was i
and i am today too
in in certain areas of my life but it
was like
i'm gonna do whatever i got to do to be
the best player i can be
within re like within the rules right
but
steroids were regular rules so those
were within the rules at the time
no no they were breaking the rules they
were yeah they were so and so there was
a day where i had to make a conscious
decision
it's like i'm not going to kill i'm not
going to sit here and lie to myself
because i wasn't like hooked on
painkillers i wasn't drinking
alcoholically or nothing like that at
that time
i was like is it worth it
and it was and it i it was yeah i mean
looking back at everything and and you
know what it was worth it
and the least amount of that worth it is
monetary
even though it made me it helped me make
millions of dollars right
the least the greatest worth and value
in that are the lessons learned
in life from taking them but at the time
you didn't know that though no
right but i had to make a conscious
decision on will i ever
look back and regret and saying like
what could i have
been ah you know what i'm saying so i
was like i'm gonna go to any lengths
plus
and this is not to like i'm not like
blaming anybody but
the atmosphere was like you know the
end of the 70s that happened so this was
1983-84
so who won four championships in the nfl
in the 70s steelers
right i thought it was maze backers
still no they were the ones that's right
remember they won two in a row
or bradshaw yeah and all those guys and
they're
like you know gary olshansky was out
there i don't know him but
but webster and uh steve course and all
these old linemen
they were i mean all jacked up right and
it was obvious
yeah and i was like in my head and and
my brother
kind of felt the same way was like the
only road to the nfl
is through steroids or at least it's a
spoke in the wheel
yeah and especially i think as a white
guy you got to get
you got to get on something you know for
what i mean just
no just oh i think no you just got to
get if i'm a white guy i'm getting on
steroids you to play anything listen can
you imagine if you
if someone had a drug for that yeah oh
man um how rich they'd be
oh yeah your brain is bigger well hell
we sell them half of our ads
i remember one thing that got me i
remember about
and i've just we haven't had anybody in
here i don't think that's ev that has
ever done steroids that i knew of so
it's like
it's just for me it's interesting to
talk about because we talk about it on
the podcast sometimes over the years and
um so i remember being in class one day
and some kid was a new kid in class and
he thought i was going through the
the aisles picking up people's papers or
something for the teacher
and he thought i was the teacher's
husband
and i think because i've been doing
stuff i was suddenly listening to you
yeah i just looked stronger right and
you know
and i just the you know at that time the
thought that somebody
would you know i would be married to
somebody that knew first of all they
even knew mathematics as well as this
lady did
you know like it almost just was
flattering you know right holy
[ __ ] yeah you think that's my wife
that's pretty much the older woman right
she drove here
you know what i'm saying like this is a
real lady over there um
but i just remember that one moment that
like
i don't know i just felt like people saw
me i just felt
more confident i felt stronger my i just
and right right then man those feelings
were feelings that i never had
are they good or what oh right bro they
were so good right
they were so good and then uh but you
also did the work
you also worked out right oh i was we
worked out a little bit right and i
you know dieted properly and i you know
you would get on milk thistle and all
the other
things you would hear about to kind of
take care of yourself um
but it was definitely like it was
interesting how i went from if you
asked me two weeks before would you ever
do steroids i just said no way
but then suddenly i was over a line
right
and for me in a lot of my areas of life
that
that became something sometimes i really
don't want to look at the truth that
there's a lot of lines that i've crossed
in my life that
i probably wish i hadn't you know i
remember thinking
oh i'll never hook up with a married
woman you know and then cross that line
just like right
things that like like where you're
saying like certain kind of boundaries
or where where who you
are and things that you do will and
won't do right i had those things but i
always went past them and then would
live and still probably
live with a ton of the shame from a lot
of it good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah